the Trump Camp released a video
exactly at the moment I guess the
Twitter space crashed yeah and so I want
you I want to play this guys for you uh
play this for you guys this uh contrasts
the Trump campaign with the Santa's
campaign at the same time that he was
launching
the Washington established politicians
like to talk about how they can be just
like Donald Trump the truth
there's only one Donald Trump
only one who gave us the largest tax
cuts in history who gave vets the health
care they deserve and stood up to China
and protected your job only one who kept
us out of endless Wars while destroying
our terrorist enemies only one who
fundamentally changed the Supreme Court
was called the most pro-life president
in history and relentlessly protected
our second amendments
for Trump Impostors make America great
again when there's only one starting day
one who can make America great
again I'm Donald J Trump and I approve
this message
look how like very epic this video's not
this is not an announcement when Trump
made his announcement earlier it was a
lot lower energy but still better than
Sanders now I'd like to play for you a
DeSantis War Room clip released uh just
about 45 minutes ago and uh here here it
here it is one second if you remember
that the music I'm sorry the music that
Trump had we need an honest Reckoning
about what happened during covid I mean
the only honest Reckoning is that all of
those agencies all of the elites the
public health establishment they failed
they instituted bad policies okay I
can't play anymore why is Elon Musk in
this yeah what is this video it's the
weirdest this is the weirdest war room
post I've ever seen of anyone's war room
in the history of War rooms this is
crazy
I
I'm just I'm I'm when that space
happened and I got my phone open and I'm
sitting in my living room and I'm like
all right let's hear it I just went no
they're disconnected are you kidding me
Barack Obama so a lot of people uh I see
one Super Chat you know people are
saying like well what about the policies
we know the policies are good we've
repeatedly said policies that's why we
want but did Barack Obama get elected on
policy yeah did Donald Trump get elected
on policy sort of Donald Trump gets
elected by being authentic by going on
stage and when the me when Megan Kelly
tries calling about saying you call them
in fat pigs did he go well no I I you
were mistaken he went only Rosie
O'Donnell and everyone started busting
out laughing he didn't he didn't deflect
he didn't say well that's not true
that's out of context he didn't try
lying he just owned it he owned that
they were in a smear I was like yeah
Rosie O'Donnell she's like wow it is
impressive to see the media take a swing
at the king and Miss yeah with this oh
man well that's the thing well no I just
want to say everyone's going oh but his
policies are good his policies are good
we know that's why this critique is
important because we're saying we want
the policies that he's going to promote
in this country to flourish in order for
them to be able to do so he has to be
elected right and whether he's elected
in the primaries or whether he runs for
president later on whether it's it's the
2024 cycle or 2028 this guy has to do
something about his presence Barack
Obama blew up kids and got reelected yes
so when you come and you're like but the
policies I'm like no I know the policies
are great we can praise them all day and
night I can say it over at best Governor
best policies fighting ESG fighting the
weakness man I love that stuff and then
he goes up on stage to speak in front of
a bunch of Americans who don't pay
attention to politics who don't know
anything about policy and he goes I
think truth it matters in this country
and they're like who is this born
exactly it's boring Barack Obama was a
celebrity he got elected because he was
Charming look at Trudeau they said
Trudeau got elected because women found
him attractive or I'm sorry I should say
women voted for him many said they voted
for him because he was attractive he was
dreamy or something he did that uh that
yoga handstand the desk and he's a
surfer and they're like oh wow people
don't look to leaders based on doing
deep analytical research on their policy
positions they vote for them if they
have Charisma exactly and and by the way
I think it's a good thing all the
elections today are decided by low
propensity
swing voters and swing districts and
swing States so when you when you break
you want to break this down Republicans
vote for Republicans Democrats are going
to vote for Democrats and you have this
fragment that exists of people who
really don't want to vote and the
Democrats are chasing down those voters
and those ballots better than we are so
it's like who's going to Hype up their
people more and give people more energy
to go actually chase down on this
ballots and build that and exactly so
you might be sitting there saying like
why vote based on policy yes no me too
that's what you should vote vote based
on guess what that's not why most people
vote so we got to figure out what makes
most people vote really make somebody
win and then if you want DeSantis to win
if we want DeSantis to win we gotta find
a way for him to cultivate those things
if those policies really matter all that
much to you it's Charisma if you have
Charisma you can you'll be able to
convince voters you can convince voters
without a message that's what hope and
change was that's what make America
great is it's a it's an empty shell that
people can fill with whatever they
believe is important you can take this
message and then you get to go ahead and
put your values into it and that's so
really all you need is Riz all you need
is charisma all you need to do is be
able to convince people someone said uh
on Twitter we lost Tina Turner and Ron
DeSantis on the same thing oh wow oh
they come in threes I'm just I'm just
surprised that when you look at Barack
Obama how I ended up winning how
Democrats often win right they got to be
Charming they got to be charismatic Bill
Clinton you've got to come out there and
you've got to speak with passion Joe
Biden
is good faking the passion and using his
his dead son as a political tool to earn
to earn sympathy I mean this guy is as
evil as they come this Hannah seems like
a good guy but nobody went to him and
said we're going to get you some some
training
nobody nobody said hey we that was a
little dry can we try it again he had
nobody's in there being like when you
say freedom say freedom don't say
freedom no Freedom yeah freedom
well what concerns me more is that
nobody was on his campaign and I know
some of the people that run his campaign
great people but nobody was on this
campaign that went hey maybe we should
really turn this into an entire like a
really well planned event like as if it
were live like we shouldn't build this
thing out to make it seem like it's much
bigger than just the Twitter space
because we can make it seem like
everyone's listening on Twitter but that
it's a bigger thing that they're not
there a part of and now they're part of
something that's bigger that would have
been a bigger grander plan I mean it
just it just goes to show that the
energy is not there with Ron DeSantis
but the energy is not there with his
campaign and the people are surrounding
him that are figuring out what actually
works with with the Maga base that they
have to try to court which they're not
doing at all that's how you have to win
you have to pull away some votes from
Trump so you've got DeSantis basically
saying what Trump is saying in no way
saying the only thing he's offered as to
why he's better than Trump is that he
doesn't think Trump can win it's like
okay if that's your attitude then people
are going to be like okay I'll take
either one you're you're not making the
argument for vote for me because I'll
win you're making the argument of either
way it doesn't matter
um yep it's really it's it's ridiculous
if he's like well I think I'll win it's
like okay your policies are the same all
right see you in November well and
that's also yeah that this is the
mistake the Republicans have made in the
past we saw this with the lack of a red
wave during the midterms the entire
Republican narrative was Red Wave Red
Wave Red Wave there's going to be a red
wave and so there wasn't any actual
unified messaging about anything else
and they just assumed that they were
gonna step in there and claim all these
victories I think DeSantis is probably
making the same assumption based on his
behavior he's thinking I'll just step
into the ring against Trump and I'll win
because I'm more electable well dude you
got to work up to that you can't just
make that assumption Milo was right when
he came on the show and he said that Ron
DeSantis had the uh Charisma of
something off-putting like when you
reach for something and accidentally
touch something moist like a wet sponge
I don't know I would go that far I just
he really bored me he was saying things
that I completely agree with I should
have been cheering for that speech and I
was yawning but honestly that's what
he's been told to do though right I mean
they're like we need to win female
voters back we went we need to win mom's
back well guess what guys in a primary
if it comes down to men vote for Trump
and women vote for DeSantis Trump's
gonna kill the santis because more men
are gonna show up for the primary or not
only that but a lot of a lot of
the women who are voting are not going
to just be for DeSantis because
descendants is calm if they're primary
voters it could be a coin toss yes but
then guys are more likely going to be
attracted to the gruff aggressive
attitude alpha male but it could be if
if all all the head is rolling is
rolling for us maybe people would prefer
my attitude more and I said it before
right if we had someone as good as Trump
but with a better demeanor it'd be great
but Ronda Sanders doesn't have the
leadership Charisma to win now if he
wins the primary he's got my vote no
question yeah of course is fantastic of
course his his policies are only
mediocre because in my opinion if you
look at Trump's announcement the ones
that we went over the other night I have
significantly more uh Stronger
preference for the stuff that Trump was
talking about than DeSantis DeSantis
gave the standard Republican
stuff I mean it was as as boilerplate
boring everyday Republican as it can get
and that's I think that's because he's
trying to say look I'm not as Extreme as
Donald Trump even though he's going to
say he's gonna try to attack Trump from
the right apparently is that that's the
that's the the goal I guess but it's
even still if you look at Trump's the
the list that Trump gave the other day
that we were going over compared to
DeSantis I think that Trump is actually
offering better has a better grasp on
the things that I'm interested in like
really tearing up the bureaucracy well I
was out whether or not he actually will
do it I don't know but I was at
Mar-A-Lago for Trump's announcement and
I remember everybody going wow he came
in really soft he was so soft he was
like so I don't know if you remember
who's or if you guys talk uh just talked
to a really little voice and when I do
it that's because Trump needs to be more
soft Ron DeSantis needs to be more alpha
male to sell himself and he didn't
really produce that tonight yeah so you
made an interesting point Phil about the
fact that DeSantis is going to try to
attack Trump from the right and this is
what always happens during primary
Seasons right when Republicans primary
they try to be as far to the right as
possible so that they can appeal to the
hard-line conservative base and then
when people on the left are running in
the primaries they're as far left as
possible and then when whoever is
selected is in the national election I I
don't remember saying all those things
or those things aren't relevant whatever
it is but with DeSantis part of what's
really a massive weakness for him is the
thing that he was best on the thing that
the American people were most impressed
with him about was his response to covid
now unfortunately it is the case that
while at the time the things DeSantis
was saying were completely unorthodox
The Establishment entirely rejected them
most Republicans would not want to
associate with you if you were saying
those things because the political
science has changed to quote DeSantis
these are perspectives that you're
allowed to have so that takes a lot of
desantises edge away unfortunately even
though he was on the right side of this
virtually the entire time because the
status quo is changed he doesn't seem
like an outsider anymore yeah point
well and that and that's what happened
to Cruz right was Cruz was The Outsider
in 2016. Cruz was the outside guy
everyone was like oh I want to vote for
Ted Cruz it's a little bit naughty you
know with all this because the
establishment was going to attack every
single person that supported Cruz Cruz
had this massive following he has I
think he had the most like
okay one Iowa it ended up just being
barely but he he had all the most small
dollar donations and then all of a
sudden it just imploded because all
these establishment guys dropped out
dropped out drop down started supporting
Crews well guess what if establishment
guys are dropping out and all these
consultants and all these different
states are trying to get contracts
they're not going to to Donald Trump for
the most part they're going to be going
to Ron desantis's group and he's going
to have a plan to have to deflect these
people and there's no plan the uh last
year I was saying that I was I was
leaning towards DeSantis I was ready you
know I've never been a big Trump guy
Trump wouldn't stop talking about me me
and talking about what was taken from
him he needs to get back on that message
of this is what they took from you he
needs to get back on the message of you
know with your help my election brought
you a better economy safer borders
better jobs et cetera an end to Middle
Middle East conflict and then they took
that all the way from you when when Joe
Biden became the president that's his
angle
after this launch from monosantis I I
have just lost like because I'm like I'm
like leaning towards Trump Trump's the
guy who's gonna go in and clean things
up but you know detention maybe at this
point I'm like 85 for Trump because um
it just
the the the the inauthenticity of it
yeah the the Twitter space was scripted
his speeches they're scripted Donald
Trump is a guy who just gets up there
and starts talking and then they go oh
no oh no he's going off the prompter
again he's he's he's he's he's ad living
and he's funny Trump trump is funny he's
he's personable
and uh he's got some he's lucky he
certainly crass and crude and can be
very insulting to people who are mean to
him but what I'm what I'm trying to say
is when he gets up there and talks he
talks in the heart and he just goes for
it DeSantis gets up there and he reads
from his piece of paper in a very stiff
and robotic way and that says thank you
and then walks away and I'm like I don't
even know if you mean it like you were
saying about singing gotta believe it
well I mean every single politician in
2016 I was chairman of Maricopa County
of the Republican Party Maricopa County
we hosted Trump for the what became the
first Trump rally
and I got a chance to meet every single
candidate that ran back in 2016. and
remember we had like 16 of them or
something I can't remember what it was
15 16.
and every single person that you meet
typically in politics is totally
inauthentic they suck you know I mean
even like Ted Cruz like he wouldn't even
talk to people sit in the back of his of
his car that we with a driver playing
Plants versus Zombies the entire time
and it's like Donald Trump when you meet
him he like shakes your hand he's like
I like your tie I like how you're doing
that tell me about your life let me see
your kid let me hold your kid let me you
know is this your grandma oh she's so
sweet she has softer hands than you like
stuff like that and like you like the
guy immediately and there's nobody
within politics thus far that I've ever
met that's that authentic that actually
cares about you anybody who went to a
trump rally saw it when the rally ends
he walks up to the barricade and starts
just hanging out with people and I was
like how does this guy have the energy
for this yeah well and that's the thing
about Donald Trump right he really is a
once in a lifetime kind of political
leader there's nobody who I'm aware of
in American political history who's even
remotely like him he's very unique For
Better or For Worse some people don't
like that I like that a lot and there's
not gonna be another guy like him who
comes along no you're right there people
can learn from this it's like guys like
learn from it and that's what I would
also say is if you're heavily invested
into santis and your position is
DeSantis is way better than Trump and
you believe that okay then you should
want DeSantis to learn some of that
Charisma so that he has a Fighting
Chance
yeah but but don't sit around and act
like there's not a problem when there is
one there is a Charisma problem with
DeSantis I like him you can't pretend
that's not true it is bad it will do no
one any favors to pretend that's not the
case but it's like the Democrats who are
trying to pretend that Joe Biden didn't
have dementia when he was running in the
primaries like you can't not acknowledge
this because this is going to get him
torn to shreds on the national stage so
I think Trump I've said this to people
before I think Trump is like Reagan on
steroids what people liked about Reagan
was that he would get up he'd make jokes
and people were like oh he kind of
reminds me of like my friend or my
grandpa or my uncle like that makes
jokes all the time at Thanksgiving and
like I like that about him and like
Trump is like like Reagan on steroids
when it comes to that but it's why don't
people I don't understand like how
somebody's running for president and
it's like you don't learn from at least
pieces of that element studying from any
other president in history yeah just
like like the successful ones that are
like that do well Florida's never had a
president have they I was reading
something that said Florida hasn't sent
has never sent a uh no president I
changed my mind then they're overdue now
uh they are new but are they the
generals or are they the Globetrotters
man it just it just bums me out to see
such a lost opportunity yeah that's it's
it's you know first impressions can be
everything and probably in a political
in a political campaign
your announcement speech needs to hit
heavy heavy and this was a was it I I
mean first of all like you were saying
it's just there's no video what is it
like radio it's like the event of radio
it's like an FDR yeah I mean they really
did not think this through yeah there's
plenty of time there is plenty of time
he could turn these things around that's
also why constructive criticism is valid
and important like I said if you really
like DeSantis you should really be
willing to hear these criticisms and the
people at his campaign should too
because I think this is what the guy I
don't think they are I don't think
they're when I tweeted enact
like about jazz Jennings because they're
living in Florida and I said where's
DeSantis his press people start
attacking me on Twitter call me a
grifter they're so out of the they're
they they I can't believe how bad how
bad this is no I'm sorry I couldn't
believe it it's just somebody's telling
them like here great policies here's
what the people want is that great and
then he goes on stage and just goes
and then his press people are like no
one better insult Ron DeSantis okay well
if your immediate reaction to any light
criticism is to start insulting those
you may as well just be a Democrat you
may as well join the left because your
candidate's never going to improve and
you may as well just be a cult you made
an interesting point about Charisma you
said it makes you feel like that person
is your friend I was thinking the exact
same thing a little bit earlier people
don't realize this you know having that
charismatic power is something that a
person might see as a thing that a
politician needs and therefore a
politician's trade and something that
actually sets you apart from Ordinary
People but it's the exact opposite when
someone isn't charismatic they come off
like any other politician and people
aren't as patient and they're not as
interested in hearing what they say
because it comes off like you said as
fake just comes off as you know this
guy's reading off of a script I'm not
doubting desantis's sincerity I think he
believes everything he read there I'll
say it again I like DeSantis but he
really has to work some energy up he
really needs to get some coaching on how
to be more charismatic nobody in this
room needs a script to explain their
position on the border on crime on war
and on woke ideology yeah no script and
in fact if you were to go up to anybody
in this room and the public and say give
me your thoughts on Modern power
politics and tell me how you feel it
might start soft and then it'll slowly
escalate as we get more impassioned yeah
and and and pulls up that anger of the
things we're frustrated with the things
we want the average Trump voter could do
a better job the average in my opinion
you take a random Trump voter put them
on say to the microphone and say rally
the people and tell them why you're mad
and it's going to be some middle-aged
you know Factory workers and say I lost
my job when they opened up those borders
and they bring in non-citizens to reap
the benefits of my labor and then put me
out of work and the crowd goes well
that's screaming Ron does our borders
are open right and we shouldn't allow oh
man well I I don't think it's a lack of
sincerity I think that there are just
some people who are more monotone their
temperament is such that when they say
things it's less exciting and
interesting again I think that's
something you can work on I think that's
something that could genuinely improve
and and by the way room for improvement
is not just a euphemism for you're bad
at this it means you actually could
become better I think DeSantis could
become better at this you brought up a
really interesting point which kind of
overtures with what we were talking
about which is this should have been
programmatic there should have been
someone warming the stage up they should
have built this thing to like a million
concurrent you know listeners or
whatever they should have set a goal
like a bar like Hey we're not going to
send it shouldn't have announced it they
should have announced it it's just got
this thing like organically everybody
get on Twitter right now but look
you said something that's really
interesting Donald Trump has done since
day one our very first rally which
turned into was the first Trump rally he
his team and I think this is core
Lewandowski deserves a credit for this
they had invited Angel moms which were
the moms for everyone that's a listener
everyone here knows this the mobs who
had a child die at the hands of an
illegal immigrant and that happened in
Arizona this was the first rally was on
illegal immigration but he had invited
those people so before he got up they
had like they had done exactly what you
said yep they appealed to the audience
and they're like oh wow I've never seen
a politician do this before so by the
time they got up like everybody was like
in the room like he did like they could
have done that like again Lessons
Learned From they could have said
nothing posted no videos they should
have done it on uh maybe Joe Rogan if
Rogan would have him but like a Big Show
and it should have been on a platform
that can handle it and then what happens
is one I'll report the announcement they
tweet out Rhonda Sanders could tweet I
am joining whatever show
to discuss you know to discuss a big
change in my life tune in you'll get a
mix of people saying is this gonna be an
announcement is it what's going on it's
got to be the announcement two million
three million people would be watching
and then you would say you guessed right
I am announcing I'm running here's why
that could have at least made up for
some of the Charisma Gap yeah instead
they did this wonky poorly planned thing
and I mean poorly plan in the sense that
they announced in advance or it was
leaked in advance then they put up a
video so it pulled all the wind out of
their sales a bunch will probably say
okay I don't need to watch it thanks I
already know He already announced then
they had the problems on the stream
itself it's you know what I think I
think they're sitting in their planning
room and someone goes what if we we
announced on Twitter with Elon oh that's
a really good idea let's do it and you
know I was like sure okay and then they
didn't no planning no planning No Tag no
no uh no program you got to think about
what happens before you got to think
about what happens don't gotta think
about what happens after when we do
shows like this let me tell you my
friends we have I believe four different
internet systems I'm not gonna say too
much more than that for security reason
but we have backups upon backups upon
backups now people have pointed out
they're like Tim your shows have had
problems before in the past uh yeah
technical issues do happen we've had our
backups fail we've had weird technical
glitches no problem we are not running
for president yeah no and when there is
100 million dollars
we don't need billions of dollars we're
doing a YouTube we're doing an internet
livestream show on YouTube well there
there are backups for this live stream
show and when I do finally formally
announce my candidacy for president of
the United States we're going to make
sure the infrastructure is in place so
that it doesn't cut out or crash
someone someone said that he did take
authenticity training let me let me
double check that is that true someone
said he should have gone to Alex Stein's
show he failed seriously if he went on
on Alex Stein or or Glenn Beck
it would have been way bigger
I mean my my biggest takeaway from this
whole thing is exactly I think what the
natural which is like how is Rhonda
santis going to be able to hold up
throughout this race with Donald Trump
and he's just gonna and what's what's so
sad about this which I think really the
undertones of everything is is that I
think everybody wants Ron DeSantis to
succeed yep I think I think everybody
wants Rhonda santis no to be around in
2028 and 2032
and and to learn from it and to and to
pull from the base and listen to the
bass and listen to the Grassroots
but what everything that's that this is
looking like is that it's the opposite
no I I don't care who it is I want the
person that's going to go into the
government and harm the bureaucracy as
much as possible I don't want someone
that knows the ropes or whatever I don't
care what they know I want them to know
that they're cutting bureaucracy that
they're getting I wanted to get rid of
cabinet level bureaucracies cut them get
rid of the entire Department of
Education like like make real substance
substantial cuts and if DeSantis is
going to be like well we'll go in and
we'll go ahead and we'll change some
people around no not good enough for me
I want Cuts I want serious hacking with
a machete to the federal government but
I don't I don't know that Rhonda that
Donald Trump will do that either
necessarily but I do think he'll get
revenge on the bureaucrats so I I don't
know what Rich bear said but I did find
a tweet from David Marcus who said this
is the most embarrassing thing that has
ever happened to a presidential
candidate it's not close just hold a
rally
yeah man all right well let's move on or
do this yeah seriously just could have
done this like do a massive rally it's
like oh my gosh this is like Trump
here's here's the reality if they did it
on Rumble I think it would have been a
lot bigger but probably still would have
crashed not trying to be mean we use
Rumble infrastructure but it this isn't
heavy undertaking if they just did on a
YouTube show they would have been the
official social media launch thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time